in this video I want to talk about a few
things that are important to
understanding biochemistry so I called
this video the biochemists toolbox and
includes understanding redox reactions
anabolism and catabolism which makes up
metabolism and reaction coupling
understanding these concepts will help
you understand different pathways
including by call us is the TCA cycle
the electron transport chain that a
bunch of other different things so the
first thing I want to cover is oxidation
and reduction you probably probably
already learned about oxidation
reduction in a general chemistry class
and if you recall oil rig or Leo ger
oxidation is the loss of electrons and
reduction is the gain of electrons so
those are this is kind of the chemistry
definition this first thing that I've
written here in biology it's always easy
to see in it particularly in biochemical
reactions it's not always easy to track
electrons and where they're going so
these two other definitions here second
and third which I've written in green
that are a little bit sort of helpful
and kind of allowing us to understand
oxidation and reduction reactions or to
visualize them a little bit better so
oxidation reactions are reactions in
which more bonds to oxygen are created
okay or more bonds to a more
electronegative atom
okay so oxygen is an electronegative
atom and actually the name oxidation
comes from this idea that you're
creating more bonds to oxygen in an
oxidation reaction whereas a reduction
is your gap you you reduce the number of
bonds to oxygen so you have less bonds
to oxygen or less bonds to an
electronegative atom and now kind of a
give examples here in just a moment
oxidation can also be seen as a loss of
bonds to hydrogen or the loss of
hydrogens whereas reduction is sort of
the gained hydrogen so let's kind of see
how these examples work with this here
we have some sort of alcohol some are
chain and this carbon here and then this
alcohol group is o H group now if we
turn that this compound into a an
aldehyde here then what we have is we've
created here we only had one bond to
oxygen right
now we've got to bonds to oxygen this
carbon here will has a single bond to
oxygen whereas here we have a double
bond to oxygen so this blue arrow
indicates an oxidation reaction
okay now let's abbreviate that as oxyde
okay
so here and in addition to that right so
that's that's sort of definition number
two more bonds to oxygen we had one of a
single button now we have a double bond
so that's an oxidation reaction another
thing is that here we had a hydrogen on
this on this o right here but over here
we've lost that hydrogen right so we
lost that hydrogen this is an oxidation
reaction now notice that the reverse
reaction which is indicated by this
arrow here would be a reduction reaction
okay so we're reducing the number of
bonds to oxygen and we're adding this
hydrogen here okay now this is important
to keep in mind especially when we think
about these things here nad+ and nadh
and fadh2 nad plus and fadh2 coenzymes
which are basically things that non non
enzyme components that actually help an
enzyme catalyze a particular reaction so
these things are coenzymes and they're
going to be very very important in redox
reactions in the pathways that we're
going to talk about first one being like
Allah says so here nad plus is going to
NADH so what happens well it's picking
up electrons right so if nad plus plus
electrons that means it's already being
reduced okay in addition nad plus add
this hydrogen here to become NADH so
this reaction this forward reaction
indicated by this orange arrow again is
a reduction reaction because we are
gaining electrons and we're adding this
H and normally normally this electron
thing is not really shown so shown as
nad plus goes to NADH but if you see
that nad plus picks up an H you can
assume that to be a reduction reaction
and of course on the flip side going
backwards in this reaction would be an
oxidation reaction right going from NADH
to NAD+ and this h plus and in these
electrons and it
losing the electrons losing the hydrogen
that's oxidation okay another one is FA
D so FA D going to fadh2 picking up
hydrogens picking up electrons that's of
course a reduction reaction and here
going backwards right losing the
hydrogen losing the electrons that's an
oxidation reaction so I put all these
blue arrows being the oxidation
reactions in the orange ions being the
Ridgid reduction reactions um in
addition what I want you to keep in mind
is that both of these here right since
they um these are both in the oxidized
form okay because they if you think
about nadh and fadh2 they're carrying
the hydrogen's they're in the reduced
form now these are going to be very very
important these things will go go
through and become reduced and oxidized
back and forth in different pathways and
you should be familiar with what's going
on in each one so I've put this example
here an enzyme that we're going to be
talking about later called lactate
dehydrogenase and actually the reason I
mentioned that is because whenever
you're thinking about a dehydrogenase
enzyme you should consider
dehydrogenation sort of associate
dehydrogenase with redox reactions so in
this case if I if I see an enzyme that
named dehydrogenase I automatically
think okay it's a redox reaction
something was oxidized something was
reduced that's not which is something I
wanted to mention here oxidation and
reduction always occur together if
something is losing electrons something
that something else has to be gaining
electrons okay so in this reaction here
sort of scroll down just a bit we're
going from pyruvate to lactate now if we
number these carbons just to make things
a little bit simpler on ourselves one
two three has really small but one two
three what's going on well in this
reaction we're going from pyruvate to
lactate notice that this carboxyl group
here nothing changed so whatever
happened in the reaction did not happen
first carving over here this methyl
group on the third carbon again nothing
changed the change occurred at second
carbon we went from two bonds to oxygen
right this carbon is bound once to this
carbon once of this carbon and twice to
an oxygen that same carbon here is still
bound to this carbon and this carbon
nothing changed there but now it's only
has one bond to oxygen and one bond to
hydrogen so we reduced the number of
bonds to oxygen and we added hydrogen's
so those this pyruvate was reduced to
lactate so pyruvate let me write that
here pyruvate was reduced to lactate to
become lactate so if it was reduced
something else was oxidized in this case
we're going to think about NAD+ and NADH
so what would have been oxidized
well if pyruvate was reduced then we
must have gone from nad plus or should
be NADH to nad plus how do I know that
we're going from NADH to NAD+ the reason
I guessed that and instead of saying
NAD+ to NADH is because if this thing if
this thing was reduced then something
must have been oxidized NADH is the
reduced form so it's the form that can
be oxidized into the oxidized form the
nad plus okay so this thing here is
being oxidized it's losing that hydrogen
this thing here is being reduced this
carbon is gaining hydrogen's okay
so hopefully that sort of makes sense
this is why I mentioned that oxidation
reduction always occurs together
something is losing electrons something
else has to be getting the electron
something is being reduced something
else has to be oxidized so it's very
important to kind of keep that in mind
to be able to tell whether you're going
to have an NADH going to an nad plus or
annnddd plus going down and NADH just as
it heads up this reaction is actually
lactate fermentation and it occurs in
animals we'll talk more about that later
hmm excuse me so Owlman score back up
here a little bit and I'm going to talk
about anabolism catabolism both of these
make up metabolism so metabolism is just
the whole idea of like chemical
reactions in our body it's made up of
Annapolis
catabolism anab ilysm if you think about
and now what I think of an out anabolism
I think of anabolic steroids anabolic
steroids help you build muscle so
anabolism is sort of the building of
biological macromolecules from their
monomers so this is these are building
things building making macro model
molecules like proteins and clay ik
acids and polysaccharides and liquid
lipid polymers so a Nabal ism is the
building ok
in addition a Nabal ism anabolic
pathways are reductive pathways ok and
we'll talk more about that in the future
but I want to cut sort of get the
definition across to you now and
catabolism is the opposite is the
breakdown of biological macromolecules
into their monomer so it'd be like
breaking proteins into amino acids or
polysaccharides into monosaccharides ok
and these are oxidative pathways so how
do I remember that I just remember our
Co so our Co is actually they're like a
gas station anyway it helps me remember
so I remember an AB ilysm is reductive
and now anabolic pathways and reduction
go together and then catabolism and
oxidation go together so so anabolic
pathways are usually involve the
reduction of a compound whereas
catabolic pathways involve exceed a
tional compound so that's another idea
to keep in mind when we think about
different pathways for instance hmm the
glycolysis is a which we'll talk about
shortly is about breaking glucose down
into pyruvate so we're taking a glucose
and breaking it down so for breaking it
down that must be a catabolic process
which means it must be an oxidative
process and we'll find if that is the
case ok this last idea I want to mention
briefly is the idea of reaction coupling
reaction coupling is simply up if you
pair up reactions some reactions that
are energy requirement energy requiring
and some reactions that are energy
saying this is a theme in biochemistry
that we see so for instance ATP
hydrolysis right we use ATP in our
bodies for energy how exactly do we do
that ATP is hydrolyzed into ADP and a
phosphate group which you're probably
already familiar with what's interesting
about this reaction the reason why it
can be used in our bodies for energy is
because the Delta G of the reaction is
negative right which means that it is a
favorable process right or a spontaneous
process if it's negative basically we
can what happens in our body is that we
take this favorable process energy
releasing process and that energy that
is released is used to power the
production or the used to power
reactions that are positively have
positive Delta G's which are unfavorable
so if we have this particular reaction
going from A to B we need to create this
product but that requires energy
basically what ends up happening is that
the overall Delta G of this reaction
you'll notice is negative one point
three kilocalories so this is a
spontaneous right and favorable well I
don't want to confuse make that
confusing let me just underline it
instead the overall Delta G is negative
so what did we really do here what we
did was we use a spontaneous or
favorable process to power the
production or power the reaction that is
unfavorable this unfavorable process
wouldn't occur spontaneously but if you
couple it with a spontaneous process the
overall the overall Delta G is um
spontaneous okay so this is again a
theme that we'll see in biochemistry
okay so I hope that was helpful and keep
all these different things in mind when
we talk about different pathways thanks
for watching